pas
[Musique]
siri quatre ans de guerre une économie
exsangue plus de trois millions de
réfugiés
ceux qui sont restés au pays se
retrouvent souvent sans emploi dans la
misère
pour survivre ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à fouiller la terre
un de nos journalistes syriens est allé
à la rencontre d'un de ces fouilles
heures les petites mains qui sont le
point de départ d'un trafic
international
nous avons rendez vous avec omar 25 ans
dans la région d'alsace avant la guerre
il était menuisier maintenant je ne
travaille plus ça fait quatre ans que
les usines ont fermé
omar tient dans sa main une baguette de
cuivre c'est avec ce simple outil qui
peut découvrir des trésors
archéologiques
comme avec une baguette de sourcier omar
ressent dans ses mains des vibrations
lorsqu'il est en présence de métal dans
les environs
pour trouver des antiquités il y a des
machines mais nous on utilise des tiges
de cuivre c'est une ancienne technique
une technique ancestrale dans la région
depuis des siècles les séries ont
l'habitude de trouver des vestiges en
travaillant leurs chants pièces de
monnaie statut mosaïque poterie
pour ce fouilleurs difficile de savoir
ce que valent ces objets découverts et
qui pourrait être intéressée pour les
acheter
mais dans la série du système d tout est
possible
par exemple cette pièce que j'ai trouvé
je la prends en photo et je l'envoie par
internet à un expert turc
il la vérifient et 6 et authentique je
traverse la frontière pour lui apporter
quelques jours plus tard il a eu une
réponse de son contact turc qui est
intéressé par sa lampe à huile mais pour
lui livrer la pièce omar doit se rendre
lui-même en turquie
[Musique]
il doit donc passer la frontière une
opération délicate tous les jours ils
sont pourtant des centaines à y parvenir
pour se fondre dans la masse omar
rejoint un groupe de familles syriennes
il espère qu'il ne sera pas fouiller
les pièces archéologiques qui fait
passer son temps général de petite
taille aujourd'hui la plus facilement
les dissimuler dans son sac à dos
la frontière la voici un fossé un trou
dans les barbelés
et les voilà déjà en turquie à peine la
frontière traverser le petit groupe se
fait arrêter par des militaires turcs
apparemment aussi c'est une habitude les
réfugiés syriens ne semble pas inquiet
et il n'y a pratiquement jamais de
fouilles
les deux bouts nous allons comprendre
pourquoi
c'est cet homme qui a tout organisé
ce responsable turc fait office de
passeur ils demandent de l'argent pour
les laisser rentrer en turquie
c'est 2500 livres syriennes par personne
il autorise ensuite les réfugiés à
prendre le bus chacun peut choisir sa
destination
vous allez a qui disent allez monter
dans le bus
c'est par ces passages de frontières
régulier que des milliers de pièces
archéologiques se retrouve à travers le
monde
notre enquête continue en turquie à
gaziantep à une centaine de km de la
frontière syrienne
sur les 1 million 300 mille habitants
que compte la ville un quart sont des
réfugiés syriens
pour survivre beaucoup font du trafic
d'objets archéologiques
un commerce qui a presque eu pignon sur
rue
nous avons rendez vous avec hussein un
trafiquant qui bien avant le début du
conflit avait déjà monté son réseau
il y a quelques jours il était encore en
syrie mais malgré la guerre il a passé
la frontière sans problème
aujourd'hui il est en turquie pour
conclure des ventes avec ses clients
la pièce la plus chère que vous ayez
trouvé et elle vaut combien
autour de 75 mille dollars et c'était
quoi une pièce de monnaie en or de
quelle époque romaine
la syrie a été l'une des provinces les
plus importantes de l' empire romain
elle a vu se succéder plusieurs
civilisations majeur de l'antiquité
et combien de pièces avez vous trouvé
beaucoup mais celle dont je parle est
une pièce rare
il y avait environ 65 pièces dont une
seule rare pour les autres le prix
varier entre 4 et 5 mille dollars
avec cette vente le trafiquant a gagné
290 1000 dollars
mais ces pièces vont être vendus
beaucoup plus cher ensuite jusqu'à dix
fois le prix sur le marché occidental
je vous explique chaque pièce trouver
circule d'un trafiquant à un autre
la chaîne de vente continue jusqu'à ce
que les pièces arrivent dans les mains
d'un collectionneur
d'art
et pour les amateurs d'antiquités du
monde entier très facile de savoir ce
qu'il y a de disponible sur le marché
syrien grâce à internet comme par
exemple sur cette page facebook
intitulée commerce d'antiquités vente et
achat des antiquités tableaux pièces et
statut et on peut il trouver une petite
annonce pour les sérieux uniquement une
mosaïque tapis très beau à vendre dans
la ville d'antalya en turquie envoyer un
message privé pas de commentaires
publics s'il vous plaît
mais dans ce business tous ne gagne pas
la même chose
ce qui creuse et font les fous y
trouve des pièces sans rien savoir sur
leur histoire sur ce qu'elles valent en
termes de prix ni sur leur intérêt
archéologique
les acheteurs ceux qui connaissent
vienne et propose des prix allant de 50
à 100 $ pour une pièce qui pourrait se
vendre jusqu'à 100 mille deux cent mille
ou même un million de dollars
en turquie il y à des réfugiés syriens
qui font du trafic et il y en a d'autres
qui luttent contre ce même trafic
j à tabasser docteur en philosophie
originaire de damas il est réfugié à
antakya
aujourd'hui il a trouvé un emploi il
travaille pour l'unesco et interpol
sa mission collecter des informations
sur ces trafics
les antiquités c'est la grande
catastrophe
[Musique]
c'est ce qui a été le plus payé
par exemple tu as des choses de grande
valeur comme une statue araméenne en
bronze et en or
elle a été volée et emmené à beyrouth et
on ne sait pas ce qu'elle est devenue
personne ne sait où il est
ces enquêtes il les mène auprès des
autres réfugiés syriens grâce au bouche
à oreille le trafic fait vivre beaucoup
de petites mains mais aussi des gros
poissons qui profitent de la guerre pour
s'enrichir
les antiquités arrive jusqu'en turquie
les syriens ont placé ce l'opposition
ils les font venir ici par leurs réseaux
et puis sa part vers l'italie et dans
ces coins là
c'est une véritable mafia bien sûr que
c'est une mafia
parmi les réfugiés syriens certains
accusent le régime de bachar al assad de
profiter des pillages mohamed à 22 ans
il était étudiant avant la guerre et
aujourd'hui il est chargé de
communication d'un des nombreux groupes
rebelles révolutionnaire
régulièrement il fait le voyage entre la
syrie la turquie
il a été témoin de nombreux pillages
effectués par les syriens qui cherchent
à survivre
mais il a aussi découvert comment les
soldats de bachar al assad n'hésitez pas
à eux aussi à se servir dans les musées
il ya une semaine la ville de dehiba a
changé de mains vous avez des infos sur
ce qui est arrivé au musée
oui bien sûr dans ma mission de
communication j'accompagne les rebelles
sur le front dans certains événements
cette fois j'étais dans le secteur où le
musée situé
quand on est entré dans le musée il n'y
avait plus rien le régime l'a vidé
le régime a vidé beaucoup
d'établissements importants comme le
musée les banques et tout ce genre de
lieux
ils ont tout transporter avec eux
parce que les vestiges sont estimées à
des milliards de dollars
et le régime le sait très bien
quand il a vidé le musée des de l'ebre
il savait ce qu'il faisait
selon les différents témoignages tout le
monde aurait recours au pillage du
patrimoine historique syrien pour
s'enrichir que ce soit les milices ou le
régime de bachar al assad et même des
shs l'organisation de l'état islamique
ces images ont choqué le monde entier la
destruction par les soldats de dèche de
pièces archéologiques inestimable comme
ici dans le musée de mossoul en irak
pourtant malgré les apparences
l'organisation islamiste ne ferait pas
que détruire ces antiquités elle serait
elle aussi impliquée dans le trafic
et depuis qu'elle menace de les détruire
elle aurait en plus fait flamber le prix
de ces antiquités c'est ce que va nous
apprendre hussein le trafiquant que nous
avons rencontrés selon lui des shows
l'organisation de l'état islamique
tirerait les ficelles de ce business
avant que des sna rives dans la région
la situation était plus tranquille
les gens travaillaient comme il voulait
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
restrictions
si tu veux travailler dans ce domaine
nous avons notre pourcentage tout ce que
tu trouves doit passer sous notre
contrôle voilà ce qu'il nous dise
tu n'as pas le droit de travailler sans
une autorisation écrite de leur part et
il te faut cette autorisation écrite
pour pouvoir travailler
deiss est impliqué directement dans le
marché
toutes pièces trouvées d'une certaine
importance est acheté par des gens de
chez eux
ils travaillent en collaboration avec
des commerçants qui vendent ensuite à
l'étranger
les propos du scène le trafiquant sont
confirmées par giat qui travaille pour
l'unesco et interpol
aujourd'hui des chez d'autres milices
financeurs opérations de guerre à
travers ce trafic ce sont eux qui en
tire le plus de profits
à 22 ans mohamed jeune activiste est
bien conscient qu'une partie du
patrimoine et de l'identité syrienne a
déjà disparu
notre pays est connu pour être un pays
d'antiquités pour nous voir des
antiquités c'est quelque chose de tout à
fait banal pourtant moi quand je passais
à côté des vestiges eux prenaient du
temps pour les admirer et en les
regardant je me demandais ce qui avait
pu se produire durant tous ces siècles
passés les antiquités les vestiges c'est
remarquable
quelle que soit l'issue de la guerre la
syrie de demain a déjà perdu une partie
de son histoire
[Musique]